your body is made up of 30 trillion
human cells the cells that make up you
but you're actually outnumbered by even
more bacterial cells and these little
bacterial critters that are inside you
are unique to you they're kind of like
your own little bacterial fingerprint
and you can learn a lot about how these
bacteria affect your life by examining
your poop we found a company that
actually examines your feces to tell you
your gut health and then we're gonna
take probiotics for 30 days and see if
it can have an impact on our microbiome
hello thing to put on the toilet to poop
on to scoop a sample from and then we're
good to go
wait did they make the look the
look in this it's like perfectly swirled
like a soft ice cream cone I just don't
know that's gonna happen for me but
we'll find out I'm gonna poop on that
I'm not gonna show you that part and
it's gonna make its way into this tube
I'd like to think that we've been in a
relationship for long enough that I
could in front of you but I'm a
little nervous I just don't think I'm
ready to take that step yeah and based
on my farts it is definitely a biohazard
reboot in all the appropriate places
good on us there was a really
challenging feat and we did a great job
we also made some of our other friends
do it as well to make our sample size
bigger and we wanted to talk to everyone
and find out if off the bat anyone had
some sort of digestion issues or
concerns they might be thinking about
with the bacteria in their body I did
have IBS it's a lot better now
thankfully I don't know that other
people have this same problem but I feel
that I have a low tolerance for
spiciness both on the way in and on the
way out bloat it I feel bloated alive
not a lot sometimes like I have a very
like sensitive stomach a bit or whatever
like it's not like necessarily upsetting
like it sings often I don't really have
digestive issues just like if I eat
Popeyes like yeah I think my digestion
is pretty normal the first thing we
wanted to analyze with our poop samples
was how diverse our microbiome was and
the way that you look at diversity in
someone's microbiome is with something
called The Simpsons diversity index with
zero being no diversity that's bad and
one being infinite diversity which is
actually impossible but 0.99 for example
would be a very diverse good number so
looking at the Simpsons dive
the index for your first sample the
score that you got was 0.72 zero point
seven five zero point eight two zero
point eight five zero point eight five
zero point eight eight you were above
average
no you mentioned that you did have IBS
which could be why your score is a
little bit lower and diet is a huge when
you diet throughout your entire life not
just the day right you took your samples
it's very important I need to be better
and I just don't so I'm not totally
surprised to be honest I know this is a
very small sample size but it was really
interesting to see that the people who
had the most digestion issues also had
the least diversity within their gut
someone like Mitch had a lower diversity
score not all hope is lost he can feed
that good bacteria with prebiotic food
and prebiotic food is hate to say it
it's things like vegetables leafy greens
artichokes garlic's some things are
delicious the more you eat the more your
bacteria eat and the more diverse your
gut can become to snack on fruits like
got my desk during the day but then on
the weekends I think I go like a little
crazy in lunch I'll do like a protein
and a vegetable migraine same thing for
dinner in general you have a pretty
healthy microbiome this can continue to
nourish those bacteria by eating lots of
prebiotic foods like garlic onions I eat
so much garlic there you go does that
mean I'm gonna live longer
not necessarily another way to also help
increase your microbiome diversity is to
take probiotics or a probiotic food like
yogurts or kefir I don't know if that's
how you pronounce it but I think it is
so the next thing we did is we actually
took probiotics for 30 days and then we
analyzed our poop again yes we pooped in
a cup twice we are champions and we
wanted to see if those probiotics
actually affected our microbiome and the
diversity in our gut initially we saw
that your diversity index was 0.72 in
your second sample after taking
probiotics
it was 0.73 0.74 so pretty much the same
ok so then that means that the
probiotics didn't have a major impact on
like increasing the diversity or without
looking at the exact species that
increase in decrease it's difficult to
see the robotics really had an impact
however there's so many other factors as
well so your diet throughout that time
period even your amount of sleep and
exercise that you get impacts your
microbiome ever since it was 0.8 there
was a little bit of a dip there but
there's lots of factors that can affect
your microbiome diversity the sample
might have been early in the week maybe
that weekend I don't know your second
sample your score was 0.9 one whoa Fred
quite a significant drop in your two
samples you want to say it was Popeyes
like a two-week bender but I remembered
to take the pills what probably happened
is if you weren't eating very well over
that thank you those probably offers
probiotics probably weren't doing much
for your second sample was point eight
sit okay so went down a bit slightly
lower maybe it's cuz I ate pizza the
whole time and didn't need anything but
pizza I hope necessary dose for
probiotics let's say you're taking three
times the amount of probiotics but
you're not eating well when the bacteria
aren't going to colonize your gut anyway
you have to get right we have now
learned that you can't just go to the
grocery store or pharmacy and buy
probiotics and then expect that your
microbiome is just gonna be all good
that's because many things affect your
microbiome for example your health your
sleep how much alcohol you take clearly
how much Papa has you're eating clearly
or things like whether or not you were
vaginally birth or c-section birth it
doesn't mean that probiotics are useless
what it means is that if you're taking
probiotics you also need to be eating
healthy that prebiotic food that's gonna
feed the bacteria and just remembering
though there's all different types of
factors that will be affecting your
microbiome some Millennials you can't
just drink a kombucha and assume
everything's gonna be okay there are way
too many factors at play here and just
get some good sleep
stop drinking booze and exercise this is
a new topic in science and we're still
learning a lot but what's important to
know is that the trillions of bacteria
within you do affect your brain and your
body in fact there are toilets that
microbiologists are designing so that
they will scan your
and send your smartphone an analysis of
your feces in order to tell you what to
eat how to be active and how to keep
your microbiome healthy in the future
after you take a dump or a poopoo
instead of just flushing it away and not
looking at it pretending it didn't
happen we're gonna be wanting to dissect
it get in there and find out more about
our bodies okay I'm done talking about
poop we can move on now thank you so
much for watching the company that
helped us analyze our samples was you
bough discovery go check them out in the
description if you want to do it
yourself it's been a good day because we
were able to contribute to scientific
research I was something we wish we
could do every day thanks for watching
subscribe and we will see you next week
for a new animated video peace